so infinity pool is a movie that I can't
stop thinking about whether it's the
ambiguous ending the horrifying turns
the characters take are the fact it
makes the mundane insane something about
it just won't leave my head from the
first second I put it on it just
hypnotized me and throughout its run
time I didn't check my phone or glance
away from the screen it's something I
haven't felt since watching a Stanley
Kubrick film and this is easily my
favorite movie of the year so far
looking back at it there's so much to
unpack and throughout this breakdown I'm
going to be going through the movie's
true meaning and also discussing what I
took from the ending weirdly I actually
found myself relating to James a lot and
I actually think there's some key
character traits in them that are
Universal on a human level now we'll be
talking about some of the plot points in
the movie as they happen but I'm gonna
take it that you've seen the film and
that you're up to speed with its story I
don't want to just recap the plot
because there's so much to talk about I
think the best place to start is
actually the movies ending in it we
watch as James ends up returning back at
the resort that acted as a place in
which she was reborn after going to a
nightmarish week at this point James has
now decided not to go back to his wife
and instead he feels fully independent
and able to embrace his true self this
is ended up by the line from Gabby in
which he says men are trained by women
like him to see themselves this week
you can take some work to undo you can
take some blood now the group stage
everything so that in the end he has to
destroy personification of himself and
the weak should be seen as an initiation
trial as soon as he does that he's freed
and we even see a switch in Gabby in
which he goes from a complete psychopath
to a nurturing figure
[Music]
a few moments later
foreign
of doing a number on him and is having
to go to the opposite extreme in order
to reverse this I'm not saying that
she's a good person or anything and at
this moment I think the movie is telling
us that James has just gone from one
woman who tells him how to act into the
arms of another might sound like I'm
making M sound bad too but unlike the
group she genuinely cares for him
however James clearly feels that she
holds him down as we get a moment where
he hallucinates a scene with everyone
standing around him they're all wearing
their masks it's a sort of recreation of
the orgy and M is sat on top of him with
her hands around his throat now the
entire movie is about him stepping out
from under the control of others in
order to become his own person in the
airport we get him staring at his name
on his ticket and passport and this is
seen as being his identity however he
uses neither and he goes back to sit in
the rain by himself so he can be alone
now in order to talk about this
transformation we have to go back to the
beginning of the movie when we first
meet him the film opens with James and
Emma on a trip which he's hoping will
inspire him to break free of the writers
block he suffered for the past six years
James wrote a debut novel that wasn't
very well received and it failed both
critically and commercially completely
killing his self-esteem even his wife
Berman doesn't really regard him as
being anything special and you get the
idea that the pair are only together
because she was rebelling against her
dad who didn't want her marrying a
writer James feels like a failure and
he's desperately hoping this trip will
spark up some inspiration within him
that will allow him to somewhat prove
his data is wrong I've spoken about this
with a lot of different people who've
built themselves up from nothing and we
all agree that there's one key trade
needed in order to become a self-made
success at some point in your life you
have to have someone who's doubted you
and it's built a mentality into you that
says I'll show them this motivates you
to work longer hours push harder and
prove them wrong which can take you from
being apathetic to being inspired now I
feel like this is something that exists
not only within James but also within
the movie's Creator though you might not
be able to pick bran and Cronenberg out
of a lineup I think that everyone will
at least have heard his surname now
whenever I've seen his name mentioned in
an article it's often followed by a
short paragraph of text talking about
his world famous father looking at the
film you could even see James as a
metaphor for Brandon and he's very much
trying to prove himself with this movie
just like how James is I don't think
it's a criticism that James burkus said
he would have only been published
because of M's dad and this may be
Brandon fighting back against some of
the criticism he faces nepotism is a big
buzzword at the moment but I think this
film proves that he's easily able to
step out of his father's Shadow now M
can very much be seen as being one of
the people that doubts and makes fun of
James and at one point she even jokes
that she's finally met someone from his
fan club when they come across Gabby at
the dinner table she says that she feels
like she's a charitable organization at
this point which clearly say it's as a
sorn out for the character James leaving
her at the end is very much in Breaking
freeing going at to be his own man
because he realizes the person he is
doesn't have a future with her if we
look at the bus scene when everyone's
leaving we can catch the rest of the
care actors all together in their
couples they're acting like they're
returning to normality and the fact that
Partners don't freak out like M did is
because they accept both the good and
bad sides of their Partners they embrace
the chaos and support each other
throughout the debauchery but they're
also able to tone it down and return
back to a normal life James isn't able
to do this because he hasn't really
found someone who accepts him and this
is why he doesn't go back to M he's
someone who has to hide his passport
from her and this also represents a side
of him that he feels like he can't show
her she sees what he gets up to as being
disgusting or as the rest of the group
are far more accepting of who he is the
use of The Masks also symbolizes who
they are and the Darkness hidden within
them that's now fully on the surface now
the movie deals with duplicates
throughout and I think that this speaks
to the double-sided personality that we
all have humans have two sides to them
and we all show one side publicly whilst
having our own private side that only we
know about often referred to as the
shadow Salve this is a darker side that
I think the characters end up going as
they realize they can get away with more
and more a Sigmund Freud also came up
with the idea of the ego and the IT the
ego is the more rational part of us
whereas the aid is the Primitive side
ego plays a big part in the film and
Gabby even gets James on her side by
massaging his over his crap book it was
crap it was crap to be fair
recognize his own lack of talent
newcomer James W Foster overcompensates
with pretension it's probably similar to
a review that Brandon himself has got
before and like I said before James
might be a metaphor for him now James
ends up coming face to face with his own
hit at the end of the film and his
primitive version of him is referred to
as the dog Gabby says that he has to
sacrifice the dog and this ties back to
the idea of the new James being born
Through Blood he kills and he conquers
this and once more goes back to being
the rational ego that he was at the
start of the movie however you could
also see him returning to the resort as
being sunny at showcases he accepts who
he is that the person he became here is
the man he's become either way I think
bath could be taken as valid
interpretations with him being reborn
come the death of the dog this idea of
birth is shown literally in the film
with him sucking on Gabby's well you
know which is of course symbolic of a
baby being breastfed now I also think
the bus journey is highly symbolic of
this because as he sat on his own whilst
the others Aunt there and there along
with their quote unquote double who we
know is just the same as them now
doubles of course also play a major role
in the movie as well in the movie we of
course watched James and his wife Ben me
a couple while Sarah on holiday and this
happens in the fictional country which
is called the tolka James accidentally
kills a local farmer through drunk
driving and he discovers that the
latokans have certain rules and
traditions someone killed someone then
their son has the right to execute the
person who did it and James is then
sentenced to death whether there's
another aspect that n is in the equation
and this only happens with the rich and
wealthy those that can afford to pay a
have a clone creator that possesses all
their memories and that person is then
killed whilst the other version watches
on now what it boils down to is
basically the idea that the elite can do
what they want and get away with it
because they have the money to pay for
it when the movie ended my wife actually
turned to me and asked what the film was
about and I replied by saying and I
quote it's a metaphor for a Lads holiday
I had magalov when I was 17. now what I
mean by that is that I went abroad to
the Boost Capital spent the week
basically doing what I wanted was a bit
of a disgrace and then came home like
nothing had happened you'll often see
reports of people going out to places
like this and it's clear that the
tourists just show up treat the place
like a playground and then they end up
leaving goes without saying that the
locals get pretty fed up with it but
they rely on the tourism so they have to
allow it to happen so that they can
afford to live early on in the movie we
even catch one of the locals driving a
quad bike around dangerously and this is
part of a protest to stop the tourists
from acting like this however their
entire ecosystem relies on it so they
have to allow it to happen and let these
events play out a detective thresh is a
great example of this and we discover
that he's pretty much made a business
out of selling the doppelgangers he
doesn't really do much detecting and
instead just Wheels them in gets the
money kills a doppelganger and then lets
them free without repercussions they
then continue to do what they want he
makes a buck rinse and repeat and of
course speak to the corruption that
exists on the island and also about how
they lead us so powerful that they can
buy their way out of anything everything
is given a green light if you've got the
green now we've actually seen some
things like this happen in real life if
you live in England then I'm sure you'll
probably know about the case of Harry
Dunn and also Anne sakulis she was over
here from the US and after driving on
the wrong side of the road she hit and
killed Harry and then sped off now this
would normally be a straightforward
matter but Anne's husband was a CIA
operative and though she got diplomatic
immunity and then fled the country and
returned to the US and they refused to
extradite her out here it was a long and
agonizing time for the family to try and
get Justice and in the end and didn't
face any jail time even though she was
found guilty there's obviously a lot of
political things involved with that I
know that won't wait too far into as I'm
sure there'll be people there saying
well that's just how diplomatic immunity
Works mate ask yourself though if this
was one of your family members that was
killed in a hit and run and the person
who did it just left the country would
you feel the same about it probably not
but we see the rich in the film can't
basically do what they want because of
their position now that question of
empathy takes me into my next point
which we see demonstrated beautifully
within the film the fact is the central
characters that we follow simply don't
possess this and that's because in this
world they don't need it to fit in they
have complete freedom from consequences
and therefore don't have to view
anything as being something that they
should actually care about now this is
shown perfectly by Gabby Breton James as
the car follows him this whole time
laughing at you one shitty book
six years ago that
You're So Vain James to actually believe
that we read it it's sort of funny but
really more than anything it's
depressing hey just sitting sipping wine
screaming James is the thing that stands
out to me most in this movie and it
shows just how heartless of a person
that she is here's a guy that she got to
leave his wife and pretended to be a fan
of his in order to seduce him and get
him to turn to the dark side yet though
she reveals that she didn't even read
his book then busts out a review that
looks like the YouTube comment section
when I make a video like this agabi is
such a detestable villain because she
thinks she's something special because
of what she can do with her money she's
just someone who works in commercials
and in the grand scheme of things
probably isn't that important however
because she's rich and beautiful she has
been unable to act like how she wants
and she treats everyone horrendously the
character can't imagine what it's like
to be the people she looks down on and
she possesses absolutely no empathy now
they were meant to feel bad for James
he's also done the same thing too this
guy is shown no empathy throughout the
movie and this is showcased in his
actions against M and also his
doppelganger there's a brilliant scene
in the movie where we watches the people
in the group think they're going to get
executed and this is without the ability
to buy their way out of trouble they're
absolutely terrified we see them lined
up and get killed and then get the
brilliant twist that the originals are
fine and just watching this play out
those getting executed conteca though
and it cements how The Originals would
truly be if they were on the other side
it's possible that facing their own
debts what broke them and it's difficult
to imagine how you'd act upon seeing
yourself die either way though this
empowers them they're entertained by
watching their own ends now why this is
important is because we learn the
doppelgangers are exact copies of the
original they have their memories and
personalities and for all intents and
purposes a one-for-one copies the terror
in this moment that we see pouring out
of the doppelgangers is the same Terror
The Originals would feel if they were in
this situation but they sit there
laughing they can't even empathize with
someone who is them and instead sit
there laughing as they watch their own
deaths now I know one of the major
questions around the movie is whether
James is actually games at the end or if
he's a clone that doesn't realize it one
of the group even brings us up and I've
seen a couple of comments saying that
the cut on his faces could show that
he's been switched out I don't think
they line up with the dog though and all
in all I don't actually think that it
matters the fact is they're perfect
copies so it shouldn't make a difference
who is who and what is what these people
are still willing to torture versions of
themselves and therefore they're not
people that we should like a side with
now I do think that when it's revealed
James has been beating on himself that
he comes to this realization he locks
himself in his room and decides to
return home which is when Gabby and the
group started physically and mentally
torture him I did notice that there's
probably some parallels between Gabby
getting James's DNA after he's just
finished urinating and the authorities
taking DNA but meh that might not be the
case she of course does this without
consent and James doesn't fully realize
what he's getting into but it goes too
far and in the end he gets pulled in
deeper he also urinates on the dog's
face before the reveal so it's like both
these these moments of peeing see turns
in the character and the trip to me as a
whole low is definitely an initiation
trial that they put people through in
order to try and convert them to their
hedonistic ways we never get this
confirmed in the film but Gabby says
they put people through this kind of
stuff every year and this time around
James is their victim come the final
goodbye Gabby says she hopes to see
James next yeah this implies that this
is something that the group do annually
therefore you can draw the conclusions
that the rest of the group of couples
like James and M who are tortured like
this before they were converted James
has ordered to shoot the dog at the end
and she refers to this as creating a
transformation others likely went
through this too and they were then
reborn just like how James is in the end
he's killed as Aid and this means that
he can be the man he truly is em seeing
his reaction to this double death
shoulder what he was really like with
her out of the picture he no longer
needs to suppress this he's broken free
of the group because he doesn't really
see himself as being part of them and
returned is his own man to the place he
can be himself everyone on the bus is
happy to put a lid on there and shut it
off but James isn't able to leave this
all behind looking at the bus trip
there's also somewhat of a layer of
sadness to it as we have Gabby's husband
Al been saying he has to return to work
immediately upon them touching back down
Gabby says
which means I'll be eating alone and
rearranging the house again it is not
and there's this kind of idea that she's
off to face months and months of bit of
loneliness before she returns to this
place where she can actually be herself
it explains why she gets an obsession
over James as he does seem to at least
be interested in her outside of all the
partying now there's actually a nature
versus nurture Motif to this entire
thing as well as you can question
whether James was always like this or if
he was molded to be like this by Gabby's
actions personally I lean in more with
the idea that he was always up
but he just found a way to do it without
repercussions in watching his own
executionism seeing himself getting away
with murder and he goes back to the
resort because to him that's returning
home it's a perfect way to close out the
film and it shows the journey that he's
gone on and what's brilliant about the
movie is that you can completely toss
this interpretation to the side and see
as being something completely different
the movie has a lot of things you can
talk about and it's one of those films I
just had to discuss I looked at a lot of
other videos on it and saw the view
count wasn't that high which in most
cases would stop me from spending time
and money on writing and paying editors
however like I said this film's
completely blow me away and I hope this
video has been as enjoyable for you as
it was for me drop your comments below
and if you enjoyed it please hit the
thumbs up button and don't forget to
subscribe for breakdowns like this every
day you want something else to watch
then we've got a video on screen right
now without the way I've been poor
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace